foreign
let's go to Tim in Boston Massachusetts
what's up Tim how we doing
hey how are we doing Dr John Delaney
thanks for having me on the show you got
it my brother what's happening
um wanted to give you a call get your
advice recently had a life um sort of
situation occur that I don't have too
much experience with I recently lost my
brother-in-law took suicide ah and uh
how old was he yeah
um
uh he was 40 years old how old
40 40. what was his name
um oh if you don't want to say that's
fine that's fine yeah I'd rather not
okay you got it that's fine
um
man
is this a surprise to everybody or is he
been ill for a while
yeah I think it was sudden it was a
surprise yeah but I wanted to give you a
call because um obviously my sister
along with a lot of other people you
know currently in a moment of grief
um grieving and um this is by the way
this isn't a moment of grief
this won't be a moment of grief this
will Ricochet through the rest of
everybody's life okay yeah I agree
yeah yeah I'm so sorry thanks
[Music]
um I am too and very very sad situation
and um I I just want to make sure I'm
there for my sister
um I know her and I are very close and
during this hard time
you know I don't obviously I said
previously on the call I don't have a
lot of experience with this
um and I just want to make sure you know
I'm doing my part and everything I can
to support my sister she's going through
this really hard time
um
and you know I've never been married
before I don't have kids
um and there's another you know case a
little bit a little bit more complex um
at the time of
his death they were currently going
through a divorce so she I know she's
dealing with all of those emotions as
well
um and yeah I'm just looking for you
know I've read a couple articles online
on how to deal with um you know losing
family members to suicide and you know
certain things to say to somebody you
know when they're grieving
um or certain things you shouldn't say
you think just trying to open up my mind
and educate myself as much as I can
um you're a good brother
yeah you're a good brother man she's
she's blessed to have you
um is she live in the same Community as
you
yes okay all right
so I'm gonna kind of give you a rundown
of
um what I've told people for years
showing up in this exact situation okay
and then stop me at any point and ask
further deeper questions here
um because there's going to be call
people listening to the show and saying
yeah but what about so feel free to stop
me um I can talk too much and too fast
in these moments so stop me and say what
about this okay
um and then when we get to the end I'll
I'll leave you with a little bit of
wisdom that I've learned the hard way
um
first is basic
um body stuff
you have to eat you have to sleep you've
got to move okay
often in grief we just shut the system
down or really our system pulls us
underwater for survival and
um it's really important to have people
around you that are saying hey have you
eaten today or better yet just send food
and so it also is caretakers that you
got to make sure you're taking care of
yourself some people when they get in
this moment like really hard workouts
feel good I'm not one of those people
um when I'm grieving I have a tendency
to sit in a 60 Minute hard blow It All
Out Workout actually
drags me down but I do need to go for
long long walks a couple of times a day
okay so whatever works for you take care
of your body even if you got to set up
some accountability if someone's going
to call you and check on you okay you
got that
yeah okay she's gonna need that too
and if that's you if that is a friend of
hers I don't know who has the closest
connection to her but somebody who will
call and make sure there's food at that
house at all times
somebody who's showing up saying I'm
showing up for us to go for a walk and
there may be days you show up to go for
a walk and she's not getting out of bed
that's fine that happens but on the
whole somebody's gonna keep showing up
okay you got that one
yep okay the second one is she cannot be
responsible for your well-being
okay
I can't I can't over Express this enough
um
people who get cancer people who lose a
parent people who
um you know have somebody who passes
away suddenly
suddenly their friends and family are
calling them all the time crying can't
breathe what do I do and they find
themselves having to take care of
everybody else
see what I'm saying
yep so don't ever don't if you ever feel
like your needs are being met by her
that's a burden that I wouldn't I don't
want her to carry right now okay she
can't be your tool for recovery and so
uh here's another example you calling
every day saying Hey do you make a mow
your yard do you need me to come do this
do you need me come do this eventually
that can become a way for you to avoid
grieving by just trying to be busy by
just trying to do stuff and it puts her
in the position to have to make a bunch
of decisions don't do that just show up
and mow the yard
okay just show up and mow the yard and
show up with food make cookies and just
bring them over
um do those things without putting the
burden of should I do you want me to
what kind of what else can I I
it's so disorienting okay so that's
that's uh number two number three you my
brother have to grieve and if you've
never done that before here's a couple
of easy steps into that one um I want
you to write this dude a letter
probably a couple maybe one that tells
you how mad you are
and it might be you were mad way before
he passed away it might have been mad
the way he treated your sister that he
was getting a divorce that he cheated on
or whatever the things were okay this
feels weird because you wanna when
somebody dies we often don't want to
think or say anything negative and we
bury that part that part still is fully
alive and functional so just duct taping
over wallpapering over the bad stuff
isn't helpful during grief you gotta Own
It All so write a letter tell them how
mad you are write a letter that you're
mad that he hurt your sister
even though you know he was sick you're
write him a letter and tell him how much
you miss him and you liked laughing with
him remember that one time
write him a letter and tell him
I'm going to take care of your your with
your wife my sister
I'm gonna honor your memory right let
him know what the future is going to
look like and what you're doing for your
body is you're letting your body cycle
all this stuff through this is a
physiological experiment I mean
experience this is a spiritual
experience this is a psychological
experience okay
these things are exhausting and they're
annoying sometimes they're big tears
sometimes you just be angry sometimes
they'll just be like I have no feeling
at all and write that down I have when I
think about you I have no feeling at all
we're just getting back in touch with
our bodies okay does that make sense
yeah makes sense and um mind if I
interject absolutely increase your point
too there
um so in terms of the whole being
responsible for my well-being being
um that's one of the things I'm
currently struggling with I'm I'm her uh
younger brother so I feel like sometimes
between siblings there's there can be
that Dynamic of like oh you know always
protecting the younger one if you're if
you're the older sibling um and I feel
like that's showing up already within
the first week here
um and I have trouble like I don't want
to tell her what she should and
shouldn't be doing but for example if if
I'm upset
um and I've been through a couple
moments with her in the first week so
far where I was there when certain uh
emotional things were were happening in
live time and I I was there visiting
with her to make sure she was okay
um just you know dealing with the
everything that's going on right now not
to name specifics but um
so in other words when she sees me upset
she she's always comforting me in other
words I gotta try to I'm right now I'm
trying to not be upset around her no no
no don't take that from her let her let
her take care of you
Don't Force It
okay if you're with her and you start
weeping and she gets up to make you tea
and and
chick noodle soup whatever her her thing
is let her do that that's part of her
healing and grieving process she doesn't
need to just sit and be
um and feel like she has no utility that
she's not useful in any way what you
don't want to do is show up and throw a
bunch of burdens on her
and I realize I may be talking out of
both sides of my mouth but let her
direct the healing that comes
yeah don't put the extra responsibility
on her does that make sense
and don't go over there and act like a
robot
because at some point she'll feel crazy
that her life still feels like the
bottom fell out and everyone else is
just laughing and hanging out and it's
just kind of moved on
um there's a it's disorienting and so if
you're sad tell her you're sad
if you're heartbroken till you're
heartbroken just don't give her the job
to fix it if she chooses to lean in
great and you might have to say at some
point hey stop sit down right I'm gonna
let me take care of you for a while that
may be a conversation y'all have
um and it and I mean you're not going to
get this right all the time and that's
fine that's fine there is the the
brother sister roles man in the the
birth order rules I mean this just
happens right that leads me though to
the next thing
um by the way these letters you write
she's gonna need to do this too
and maybe I'll read them to each other
if y'all are super close or if y'all
have got other brothers and sisters and
y'all super close you all get together
and y'all all write a letter to this guy
and you read it out loud
and you grieve together that's that's
that's that's that's grief that's that's
an incredible way to do it it's
cathartic and healing most of the time
not all the time but most of the time
um you're right on with the net with the
last thing I would tell you and that is
dude just show up
just show up
say way way way less than you think
okay you don't need answers you don't
need Solutions you don't need cheap
nonsense stuff that people Stitch into
pillows about how God need an extra
angel or bullcrap like that
when she starts crying or Screaming or
weeping or saying it's my fault it's my
fault it's my fault or whatever
often the greatest thing you can do is
reach over and grab her hand and pull
her close to you
okay
yeah and man we want to solve these
problems with our words so bad and we
just start talking and saying the
stupidest things have you done that I'm
the worst
the worst about that
um no I haven't done that just yet but
you know there's definitely been yeah
I've been around it while it's been
happening but I haven't done anything to
like
yeah I'm a pretty quiet person in
general so good for you you've got a lot
to teach me good for you
um it may be that you play the role of
protector when somebody else starts you
know like a well-meaning mother or Aunt
is like well you know you can say hey
let's let's not right now
and it can be awkward and it can be
weird but play some defense for your
sister
she doesn't need to hear that Stu she
doesn't need to hear other people
running their mouths to try to make
themselves feel better at her expense
right it can be a hey not right now not
right now right now it's just hugging
time right now is just hand holding time
we have a casket to select we've got
songs to select we've got health
insurance policies to deal with and life
insurance policies to deal with in a
mortgage and car notes we've got all
this crap to deal with lawyer bills not
right now
not right now right now we're just
holding hands we're just hugging
and also showing up
again sounds like I'm talking out of
both sides of my mouth hope I'm being
clear
just show up in mow the yard
or hire somebody show up and bring a
casserole over grab a burger and grab a
second one and bring it over
and say no words and she might that
burger May sit on the counter and she
won't eat it that's fine she'll remember
my brother kept showing up and my
brother kept showing up and my brother
kept showing up
and eventually you become it's gonna
sound woo-woo and all gooey and gross
you become part of her nervous system
somebody she can rest into
her body can begin to relax finally
because she knows she's got a tribe
she's got a gang she's got people that
keep showing up
how does that sound yeah yeah sounds
good great advice appreciate it and
maybe if you can show up and just go for
a walk with her and yeah
um
just walk next to her or walk her dog
with her or hold her hand or whatever
your relationship is together
um this is a long haul and especially in
a divorce that I can imagine the guilt
will be 10x like she played some kind of
role in this who knows what's in some
sort of letter this is just a messy
messy messy time
show up show up show up say less than
you think take care of your body
um don't use her to make yourself feel
better and you make sure you're taking
care of your grief you might see a
counselor you might have to go hang out
with your parents you have to call a
couple of your buddies
you may have to write some letters to
him who's passed away whatever it is
you're gonna have to sit in the
discomfort for a season my promise to
you is it will pass
um it won't go away you're always going
to miss this dude you're always going to
remember this time
that it won't feel like your body's on
fire for her it's going to be painful
for a long long long time and hey this
is important in about a month
when the adrenaline's worn off and
the call stop coming and the Facebook
messages stopped coming and the flowers
stopped coming
your sister's home is going to feel like
a cave it's gonna feel like a hole is
swallowing up that home
and those are the moments when all the
cheering has gone away and all the
lights have gone away and all the
communities left and gone back to their
lives and your sister's looking around a
room trying to clean up the ash that's
when little brother can show up
again
some nachos a burger
a lawnmower
no words no little special Tony Robbins
sayings or anything just showing up
hands outstretched
I'm here
and I love you and I'm not going
anywhere
she's lucky to have you my brother